[Music]
a dangerous undercover world of
sleeping pills and anxiety drugs
i'm no different from the people who are
taking drugs on the street
sky news has seen evidence the pandemic
may be pushing more people to buy them
illegally online since the pandemic i've
gotten three to four messages a week
asking me to supply benzos as they can't
get them from a doctor
prior to the pandemic i'd be asked once
a fortnight or so
benzodiazepines or benzos prescription
only in the uk
are being bought on the internet from
abroad it's so
easy to find them a quick search and
you're spoiled for choice
but they're often not what they're
advertised to be
people will buy what often look like
very convincingly
packaged medication they're often fake
figures seen by sky news show a rise in
the number of benzodiazepines bought
illegally in the uk
and sent in for testing to a public
laboratory
unless we act soon around drugs
benzos it will be a bit of a pandemic
for young people
growing up and addiction will rise
kathy's perhaps not your typical drug
user well off
in her fifties you always need more
you can't stop you can't stop taking
them she's among what's believed to be a
huge number of women especially
just like her across the uk we've
changed her name and revoiced her words
for me because of the drugs a lot of my
memory and the depression was the worst
possible situation for me
i couldn't get out of bed i just felt
like life was pointless
i think that was the lowest point for me
really realizing that i had no desire
to live i just didn't have any reason
for waking up
lockdown was perfect because i just
didn't want to wake up so i wouldn't
now clean she says the diazepam she
bought online
came from india romania and pakistan
i just typed in by diazepam to the
internet
random website came up one of multiple
and i'm now in a live conversation with
someone called eddie
i've asked him can you give me a
prescription i don't have one
he said we don't need a prescription
i've asked do you deliver to the uk he
says yes
i thought it was illegal to buy them
without a prescription if i'm here in
the uk
he's clearly saying something's legal
here when it's not
the concern for some is that it won't be
obvious but without a prescription
it is possession of a class c drug
they will include tablets with variable
dosing
often with lots of impurities and most
worryingly
often with other substances that have
been substituted
dr owen bowden jones from the addiction
to online medicine clinic
warns buying on the web is risky the
real difficulty is
if you take one tablet and you think
well it seems a bit
weak it hasn't really had much effect
then you might take a second tablet
that tablet might actually be much much
stronger
and so the risk is that people overdose
they become
rapidly intoxicated and they collapse
figures seen by sky news from wedinos
the public health wells run laboratory
that receives drugs from across the uk
for testing
show the number of benzodiazepines sent
in increased during the pandemic
by 25 in 2020 compared to the year
before
worryingly there's also been a rise in
the level of substitution
compared to 2019. in the last quarter of
2020
less than half of diazepam and
alprazolam or xanax samples
tested actually contained those
substances
that's why to inject the benzos here
along with obviously other drugs
paul's a former drug addict he knows how
dangerous benzos can be
you know i've been on a few drugs over
the years you know a-class drugs
but vendors coming off of them was
hardened coming over heroin
he usually gives talks in schools on
drugs and is worried what he's hearing
is that the impact of lockdown could be
fueling a rise in use among young people
too
there's more drugs being sold online to
young people than ever you can access
any sites they don't know what they're
buying these children
i have a you know by certain social
media platforms
um by parents even students themselves
that they have been started buying drugs
online and getting involved with benzos
and
you know and their behaviors all over
the place so they can't function
properly you know education's gone out
the window
this guy wants to sell 100 valium
10 micrograms for 90 euros and benzos
are openly sold
on social media
often there's inter-platform advertising
an extensive menu from this seller um
diazepam is actually out of stock here
but 10 boxes
are 195 pounds for example so sometimes
in the comments they have
a whatsapp number or a website
in response twitter said keeping people
safe is a top priority
they remain vigilant and take robust
enforcement action
facebook and instagram said similar
buying and selling prescription drugs is
strictly against our policies they work
closely with the police and last year
they removed over five
million pieces of content connected to
drug sales
and snapchat the same they're
proactively making it hard for the sale
of illegal drugs
and are dedicated to stopping it a lot
of people call it a disease
i believe i may have a disease of
addiction meanwhile kathy wants to reach
others like her
stopping benzos i have clarity my mind
is sharper
i feel happy about life i have energy
it's like being reborn
it's impossible to know the scale of
self-medication
there are just pieces of a jigsaw
suggesting a problem before
covid may only be getting worse as a
result
adele robinson sky news